volver a casa caballero ya está el
acceso libre teresa ya para su domicilio
así empiezan a regresar decenas de
familias luego de haber sido evacuadas
por un gran incendio forestal que
comienza a ser controlado por los
servicios de emergencia en la localidad
de bellis en valencia contento de volver
turistas por ver todo lo que ha quedado
con lo poco que ha quedado las
conflagraciones de este verano han
arrasado más territorio quien nunca
antes en lo que va del año los incendios
forestales ya han quemado más de
275.000 hectáreas en españa según un
estudio publicado por la revista
británica nature geoscience el cambio
climático ha dejado partes de la
península ibérica en su nivel más seco
en 1200 años como todo ha sido tan
intenso son emociones muy dispares miedo
en certidumbre
rabia e impotencia
solidaridad el cariño a la gente todo es
muy intenso en muy poco espacio de
tiempo
el consejo de ministros acuerdo declarar
como zona catastrófica las 14 regiones
autónomas que han sido más afectadas por
las llamas con el fin de desplegar
ayudas económicas e indemnizaciones a
particulares por daños en sus viviendas
por su parte el presidente del gobierno
español pedro sánchez visitó el
municipio de bellis en el este del país
el cual se vio afectado en la semana
pasada por un gigantesco incendio que
consumió alrededor de 17.500 hectáreas
de bosque según las autoridades locales
digo más de 270 mil las personas que han
tenido que ser desalojadas como
consecuencia de estos incendios y como
saben ustedes porque son datos públicos
oficiales
este es el verano más caluroso
tenemos desde que contamos con datos
fiables en los registros oficiales es
decir desde el año 1961 así españa se
sitúa como el país de la unión europea
más afectado por los incendios seguido
de rumanía portugal francia e italia